Here's what you're going to
do with your workflow.
First off, you change your code or
you edit it inside a text editor.
Once you're happy and
you want to see what happened, you save.
Very simple.
I recommend using a keyboard shortcut
like these, which is Cmd+S on a Mac, or
Ctrl+S on a PC.
This will make your life a lot easier,
instead of going up to the menu and
clicking one of these options.
Then you swap over to your browser.
You.
You open the file
if you haven't done it yet.
But, if it is already open all
you need to do is then click
refresh to see the changes.
Here, let me show you and
example from start to finish.
First off, I have my text editor open
and I also have my browser open.
It's kind of nice to have
the two open at the same time so
you can see everything that's going on.
But, you don't have to.
Inside my text editor
I've made a change.
Notice that I added an h2 tag which is
going to be another heading tag just
a little bit smaller than the h1.
I'll go ahead and save it,
and notice here inside Adam,
that little dot disappears.
So, now I know my file has been saved.
I use the keyboard shortcut
because that's a lot faster.
Now I'm ready to see
how this file looks.
So, I'll come over to Chrome.
And I will press Cmd+O to open a file.
I will navigate through my computer and
then find it.
I've called it lesson2.html.
And I'll click Open.
Hey, and there you go.
You can see the header here and
it's the same code that's over here.
Looks pretty cool.
So what if I make a change?
What if I decide to change this
exclamation point to a question mark?
Because for some reason I'm not sure.
It is though, I know this is HTML.
I'll save it, and then I'll come over
to the browser and I'll refresh.
Now, I could click this
refresh button here, but
it's actually a lot faster to
use the keyboard shortcut.
So I'll hit Cmd+R.
And now, there is a question mark.
All right, and
that's all there is to it.
There are a few other ways of
opening files in the browser,
but this is going to be what
you'll be doing for now.
Later on, you'll actually learn about a
few tools that can do the refreshing for
you every time you save.
That's pretty cool.
And then there are also developer
tools that will let you
edit websites live without
even using a text editor.
You'll be learning about
developer tools very soon.